you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme a landmark decision
as a big oil company is ordered for the
first time ever
to change its climate policies
a cyclone yas hits india's east coast we
look at the impact climate change is
having on tropical storms
and 3 000 years in the making tasmanian
devils are once again born
on australia's mainland
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we start today with a
ruling by a court in the netherlands
that could have huge implications
for how fast emissions are cut and how
quickly we can reach
net zero a dutch court has found that
shell has a legal responsibility for
climate change ordering the big oil
company
to set tougher environmental targets and
while the ruling is only legally binding
in the netherlands it is likely to guide
deliberations by judges in other
countries too
well our climate correspondent lisa
holland is here with me
so lisa how significant is this ruling
well anna frankly it's been called
groundbreaking
landmark historic uh and basically it's
the first time that a major oil company
has been told that it
is liable for the damage that it's
causing to the climate now remember that
shell had said that it would be net zero
by 2050
but groups such as friends of the earth
and others said that wasn't good enough
and forced them to court in the
netherlands now this ruling says that
uh royal dutch shell must reduce their
emissions by 45
uh by 2030. the interesting thing of
course is that almost certainly there
will be repercussions throughout the
rest of the world repercussions for
uh wider oil companies uh shell itself
though
has uh said that it will now be
considering whether or not to appeal
but the ruling says uh that it must
start putting into
force the court's decision straight away
lisa thank you well before we hear more
about today's case let's take a look at
how we got here
the case is the latest in a string of
legal challenges filed around the world
by climate activists seeking action
to cut emissions so in december 2019 the
case of a climate activist group called
the
agenda foundation against the government
of the netherlands concluded
after four years now it was the first
time a highest level domestic court
established
a state's duty to reduce emissions by an
absolute minimum amount
based on laws protecting human rights by
february 2020
there were more than 1400 climate cases
in 33 countries the united states had
more than a thousand
followed by around 200 in australia
in july 2020 friends of the irish
environment won a case against the irish
government over the lack of specific
targets
in its 2017 plans to reduce emissions
and at the end of april this year
germany's supreme court ruled that its
climate protection act needed improving
and gave the government until the end of
next year to fix it
and today is the first time a company
has been asked to align
future policies with the paris climate
agreement other cases against fossil
fuel companies
relate to damages well let's bring in
now joanna setzer assistant professor in
climate law at the london school of
economics
and welcome to you just how unusual a
case
was this and how big a moment do you
think it is that shell has lost today
well it is as lisa said uh huge
it's groundbreaking it's the first time
that a company loses a case like this
not a case that looks into the past but
a case that looks into the future
so the repercussions of the case in the
netherlands and
certainly beyond in every country to
every company
will be huge well yes so what do you
think the implications are do you think
that more companies will end up in court
that's one so you can see how a case
like this can be replicated
in a number of other jurisdictions but
also in terms of how the case asks shell
to change its
corporate portfolio it's it it's
strategy
so uh you you really see how the
idea that courts wouldn't be able to say
something like this to a company to
determine not only
what governments should be doing but
also what companies
should be doing how this has changed
since this decision
and particularly in regards to uh what
shell has defended that
they wouldn't be able to make a change
without uh
affecting their uh their business that
this court
now says well you know that that's what
you have to do there's no way around it
and how big a role do you think that
litigation will play
in the future against both companies and
governments as well just how much is a
growing trend
in climate activism
it is a really growing uh trend what we
see
is of course you still have other types
of activism
other organizations uh doing different
types of campaigns and
until before covid people go into the
streets but what we
observe in the last years is how
increasingly people
organizations are going to courts to ask
for
that change and and this is against
governments
and as well as against corporations
well joanna setzer thanks very much
indeed
thank you it was a pleasure let's take a
look now at some of the day's other
climate news
and the environment bill has returned to
parliament today with new amendments on
nature and water pollution
it includes creating a species
reintroduction task force in england
which aims to reverse the decline of
hedgehogs waterfalls and other wildlife
the legislation is set to become law in
autumn this year
but labour wants to amend the bill to
include a new tree
strategy for england to help meet
climate targets
around 75 000 acres of new woods will
need to be planted each year
to bring emissions down to zero by 2050.
at current rates labor says the
government is set to miss its target by
four decades people could soon be able
to travel abroad on environmentally
friendly blimps
hybrid air vehicles have developed
airships capable of carrying a hundred
people
on short-haul flights the holiday
hotspots around the world
the company hoped to roll out the hybrid
electric planes by 2025 which they say
could reduce flying emissions by 90
percent
and for the first time in 3 000 years
wild
tasmanian devils have been born on
mainland australia
conservationist charity aussie ark say
they hope the
seven newborns can sustain a new
breeding population
for centuries the endangered animal has
been isolated to the nearby island of
tasmania
more than a million people have been
forced to leave their homes in low-lying
areas of india's
east coast because of cyclone yas the
tropical storm
formed in the bay of bengal on monday
before making landfall
this morning well india's meteorological
department said
coastal areas have experienced strong
winds rain
and tidal surges and it's the second
cyclone to hit the country
in just over a week sky's neville
lazarus has the latest from delhi
cyclone yas comes less than 10 days
after the western coast was battered
by cyclone tautei it had barreled up
from the southern states of
kerala karnataka maharashtra and making
landfall in gujarat killing hundreds of
people
today's cyclone on the eastern coast has
surprised everyone of how quickly
it has intensified into a very severe
cyclone with wind speeds
of 86 miles an hour in gustings of 97.
over the last decade india has had a
larger number
of cyclones hitting its eastern and west
western coast
and also the intensity of these has been
much higher
the economic damage has been enormous on
the country
affecting lives and livelihoods of
millions of people
now climate change and severe weather
events
are being talked about in the media and
civil society
india is one of the worst affected by
climate change
well dr frederico otto is from the
university of oxford and specializes in
extreme weather events
welcome to you is it possible to know
what role
climate change plays in an individual
weather event
like cyclonias
yes it is possible to know um
we don't know yet because um you have to
look
at these cyclones and extreme weather
events individually
but we do see um across the globe
um a fairly consistent pattern when it
comes to the effects
of climate change on cyclones
and that is on the one hand
basically every cyclone that is
making landfall has more rainfall
associated with it
than it would have without man-made
climate change
and rainfall is responsible for a lot of
the damages associated with cyclones
and at the same time because of sea
level rise we also see
storm surges associated with cyclones
being higher and thus more damaging than
i would be
without climate change and explain why
that happens because of climate change
in a changing climate we have warmer
surface temperatures of the oceans and
that means
that cyclones get more more energy
and uh and also can suck in um
and warmer air can also get more um
water vapor and that comes out as
rainfall
and so these high-energy cyclones suck
in a lot of
moist air that that dumps enormous
amounts of rainfall
um when when they make um yeah when they
make landfall on
on the cities and of course with sea
level rise because we have a higher sea
level
um even if it's just a little bit higher
when you have a storm coming in and
bringing them the water
on the coast it just reaches a bit
further than it would be
with slightly lower sea levels and so
there are
parts flooded that would not have been
flooded without climate change
dr freddie otto thank you
campaigners are calling on the
government to create a world-leading
ocean recovery action plan to bring our
seas
back to life over 250 000 people across
the uk
have signed a petition as part of the
campaign by sky
ocean rescue and wwf broadcaster
steve backshaw delivered the letter to
mps at westminster earlier today
it's really important now more than ever
that the people in power realize how
important our oceans
are to us and how much they can do for
for us for the animals that live in them
but also for a better positive future
for for everyone and you know
in terms of their potential for
mitigating the effects of anthropogenic
climate change
our oceans are unparalleled so-called
blue carbon can be
one of the key ingredients to unlocking
a potential positive outcome
in terms of um you know reaching our our
goals
well that's everything from us for today
coming up tomorrow i'll be speaking to
bahrain's
special envoy for climate affairs about
the impact the climate crisis is having
in the country
and how the gulf states can move away
from their reliance on oil
thanks for watching and see you then
you